hello and welcome i'm James Murphy and today we're
going to be installing python for data science.
why is installing python for data science any
different than installing python for any other
reason? well when you're working with data you
often don't know exactly what you're looking for
ahead of time. you just kind of want to play with
the data and then decide what you want to do with
it later. if you just installed python directly
you're probably not going to have all the tools
that you need in order to interactively explore
data. that's why i recommend that if you're going
to do any kind of data analysis you should install
anaconda, which packages all these common data
analysis tools for you. especially if you're new
to python this can really help because you don't
have to worry about what packages and things to
install. anaconda just comes with all the most
popular ones pre-built in. you don't have to worry
about anything. if you are watching this video
most likely you're looking for the individual
edition so let's download the individual edition.
most likely you are running a 64-bit machine
and you should choose the 64-bit option.
it's nearly half a gigabyte big so
it might take a while to download.
alright now that it's finished downloading
let's go ahead and run the installer.
click next to continue and accept the
license agreement. i recommend installing
just for yourself, that way you won't need
admin privileges. by default it's going to
install anaconda into your home directory. note
that it's going to take up nearly 3 gigabytes
of memory so make sure you have the space before
trying. go ahead and click to go to the next step.
i recommend not adding anaconda to your path
or registering it as your default python
so leave both of those boxes unchecked. then
you can proceed with the installation. okay
it finished. that took about five minutes for me.
remember it had to unpack three gigabytes of data.
then go ahead and click through the rest. i
wouldn't bother with either of these tutorials.
you'll now find that you have something
called anaconda navigator in your system,
let's go ahead and run it.
this is a dashboard showing you all the different
programs that are either installed with anaconda
or available to download through anaconda. the
one that i recommend using for data science is
jupyter lab. don't get confused with the
similar but older jupyter notebook setup.
jupyter lab is similar to jupyter notebook. it's
running the same code under the hood and it's
written by the same people. the difference is that
jupyter lab is designed to be a more all-inclusive
integrated development environment whereas
jupyter notebooks are kind of just looking at
single files one at a time. let's go ahead and
launch jupyter lab. once jupyter starts you'll
find yourself in your home directory. i recommend
making a new folder for your python projects.
go ahead and navigate inside the folder. now
we can finally create our first python notebook
by clicking on new notebook. you can rename the
notebook by right-clicking and selecting rename
notebook. and now you can just type python code
into these cells. once you've typed the python
code you can execute it using shift enter. notice
that a new cell appeared below the first one.
i can write different code in this cell and
run the cell independently of the other cell.
the state of any variables you assign is preserved
so anything that you do in a previous cell can
still affect other cells. but i can still go
back and run previous cells again if i want to.
i went ahead and downloaded a
sample csv file into this directory,
which we can now load into memory
so that we can explore like this.
as you can see i can see the data set and
decide what to do next based off of what
i see. i don't need to have the whole thing
planned out already. this is the main benefit
of using jupyter lab: you can see the data
and then decide what to do with it later.
go ahead and start playing around with it
yourself. now you just need to know how
to effectively use python for data science, but
that's a different video. thank you for watching.